when I was Hawaii I decided to leave in
the United States because I wanted to be
an author
they wanted to learn English and I
wanted to away by myself and be more
independent I was not looking for
anything I was now looking for a
relationship but then I met him
I don't have a tie but white boys not
something that I was looking for
necessarily my friend who was also his
friend we went out to a bar he saw him
and he saw me when we actually started
talking and he was just really nice he
was sweet he was goofy he made me laugh
and I liked that he'd helped me open up
more to people and to see more of the
positive and fun side of life when you
first met him I told him that I was
eventually moving back to Colombia
he seemed bummed about it but he also
was like all do what we have to do in a
long-distance relationship we were very
committed to each other they definitely
saw myself getting married to him and I
saw myself having kids with him last
year I decided to go visit him the
initial plan was that I was going to
stay with him for six months so I could
like actually get the experience of
living together and in transition into
any marine when I got to the States to
live with him I kind of like felt that
something was wrong
[Music]